on vient de recevoir la facture d'edf
entreprise 3564 euros sous 10 jours dont
qui fait qu'on va pas pouvoir les payer
en gros voilà le manoir et tous les
projets qu'on l'avait ça se termine
aujourd'hui là c'est clair c'est un rêve
qui se transforme en cauchemar fin 2018
paco et sa femme ont acheté ce manoir
pour en faire des chambres d'hôtes et un
terrain de camping
mais depuis la crise sanitaire il n'y a
plus aucun client
là on se retrouve devant les trois
mobiles au normalement il ya énormément
de personnes tous les week-ends et puis
là on n'a aucune réservation jusqu en
septembre rien et aujourd'hui
paco n'arrive plus à régler ses dettes
plus de 12000 euros de crédits et de
factures à régler sous quatre semaines
le jeune entrepreneur est au pied du mur
pour nous il ya aucune solution
financièrement trouver autant d'argent
en si peu de temps edf dix jours et les
huissiers en un mois c'est impossible
là on est dégoûté je suis un peu je suis
dégoûté moi qui avais envie d'avoir un
retour à la campagne aux sources des
choses comme ça là financièrement c'est
c'est la banqueroute
cette situation n'est pas exceptionnelle
faute de trésorerie
beaucoup de petites entreprises de la
région risquent la fermeture pour éviter
d'en arriver là
le syndicat des pme réclament des
arrangements au cas par cas
il faut la souplesse partout surtout
chaque acteur qui a les moyens d'être à
logis pour accompagner une entreprise
puisque faire l'important c'est que
quand on va à tahar poleo dh sur une
entreprise de ce type elle soit
réceptive parce que là particulièrement
mais sur un cas où la facture est
relativement importante et où donc là ça
mérite une écoute particulière selon le
syndicat patronal 5 à 10 % des
entreprises de bourgogne franche comté
sont aujourd'hui en grande difficulté
l'hôtellerie et la restauration sont les
principales victimes de la crise